so should we be doing more joining us
now to discuss our Rob lines the Science
and Technology director of the Institute
of ideas and Jonathan Bartley who's the
co-leader of the Green Party gentlemen
thanks for your time Rob if I can start
with you seems like if us being
encouraged to recycle more can only be
good for the planet there's nothing
wrong with that
I think the there's two problems with
the compulsory recycling the first is a
there are practical issues especially
people living blocks of flats and things
like that and whether it's actually
effective and but there's also a sort of
a scientific issue as well because while
people talk about recycling and helping
to save the planet actually the effect
of household recycling isn't very
trivial and actually the real big issues
in terms of tackling environmental
problems have to be done at a sort of
national and governmental level in terms
of changing the way our energy system
works for example from what I can work
out about 1% of Britain's greenhouse gas
emissions are saved by household
recycling which is trivial and
increasing the rate of household
recycling won't make very much
difference to the planet okay Rob
Jonathan let me put that to you one
percent of household recycling that
sounds like we shouldn't really be doing
it at all is pointless
I think people involved in that got 6.8
billion pound industry in this country
or their jobs or the industry that
relies on recycled materials all those
people they're trying to promote a
circular economy would disagree with Rob
but of course he's right in one respect
and that is that we need to be looking
to reduce the amount of waste packaging
and we need to make those businesses
that are being irresponsible and making
us all subsidize their poor practice we
need to make them incentivize to be
better we need to also reuse a bottle
scheme where you get put deposit back on
your bottles would be a great way
forward we've seen the huge impact that
the recent introduction of the charges
for plastic bags has happened you know
billions of plastic bags have been taken
out circulation and that's had a huge
impact not impact so let's you know
introduce a bottle return scheme and
lets you know incentivize businesses to
make the right decisions but then in
terms of recycling let's make sure that
our recycling is consistent let's not
have this face
your political leadership and let's make
it absolutely clear there is a failure
okay a political leadership around this
week we are going to know our recycling
rental rate went down last year for the
first time in years whereas their
Germany hitting things like 60 percent
okay Jonathan I can see Rob I can see
you shaking your head saying bottle
bottle scheme is just not going to work
according to you well I just think that
this is kind of like dealing with the
very very marginal issues and expending
an awful lot of sort of political and
intellectual energy on such trivialities
Rob is it should we should we not set an
example ourselves by doing this is it
not a starting point that we can do more
well I think that the thing there is a
great large degree of virtue signaling
around recycling that people like you
know parade the fact that they recycle
I'll talk about the fact that they
recycles just to confirm that they're
good citizens well if you if you want to
deal with the practical issue of
environmental problems then you have to
have a much much more ambitious outlook
about these things and what we need is
for example reliable low carbon energy
sources at the moment we don't have that
we have low carbon energy sources they
are unreliable or we have reliable
mostly fossil fuel energy sources so we
need to invest big style in and changing
that situation in getting new forms of
energy sorted out you a glass recycling
scheme or bottle return scheme it's just
nonsense is a way of dealing with these
prob okay Rob Jonathan complete nonsense
again you know absolutely we need to
invest in renewable energy we should be
a world leader in that you know 30
billion pounds subsidy for Hinkley is
such a waste of money
nuclear power when we could be investing
in a renewable energy revolution I know
rejuvenating our our offshore economy
and our offshore renewables so in that
case a lot of things should be it
shouldn't be compulsory for households
there's no point really because it's
such a negligible effect so why attack
the people when we should be as you said
previously of course we should be
attacking the sort of global
corporations I mean we've got to do all
of it we have to be investing in
renewable energy we have to be reducing
what we produce but we have to be
pragmatic and
the idea that we can just bury our head
in the sand and say well let's send it
all to landfill yeah it doesn't make
economic sense it doesn't make
environmental sense to send it all to
landfill let's you know do things right
across the board let's reduce let's
reduce reuse and let's recycle let's
create those resilient circular
economies which create really really
good jobs that make a greener more
pleasant environment and let's move
forward together it isn't an either/or
it's a both/and and you know the idea
that we should be reducing this to a
binary discussion of pericyclic be
pretty ridiculous
okay Rob according to our ocean campaign
and a truckload of rubbish of plastic
rubbish is tipped into the ocean every
single minute a lot of that will be
household plastics is it not good that
we should potentially be made to recycle
those plastics when you see a statistic
like that that you know things that we
eat strawberries and blueberries out
over ending up in the ocean and then
they end up in our food well I mean
there is a questionable probe as sort of
prosaic a question about litter and I'm
not in favor of litter and I think that
litter should be dealt with and that
that's why I'm slightly worried about
councils taking three weeks to deal with
landfill bins because I think that
that's something that could it
eventually end up encouraging more
litter yes of course we should which is
throwing things away properly but
frankly if a plastic bag ends up in a
landfill rather than in a recycling
plant it shouldn't make any difference
if things are done properly and an
interesting quirk to this discussion is
that people talk about landfill as if
it's you know throwing something away
forever actually 9 percent of britain's
renewable energy what's classified as
renewable energy comes from landfill gas
so we are getting used out of the
materials that end up in landfill and i
think we should be much more open-minded
about how we deal with waste and see
what gives us the best cost-benefit of
get written getting back some of the
resources that we put in as it were
while at the same time not overly
burdening people with inconvenience
their household recycling schemes an
expensive recycling of plants etc and if
they're not actually making a huge
difference - and the environmental
outcomes okay Jonathan just on this the
specific issue of should it be
compulsory from four local councils to
make us recycle cycle what do you think
I don't think that using the stick is a
very effective way of doing it and you
look at places like South Oxfordshire or
they alternate you know one week they do
recycling and food the next week they do
your normal waste that would otherwise
go to landfill now that's a very good
way of doing it's about education it's
about a coherent strategy right across
the board if you look at places like
Scotland and Wales where these issues
have devolved down to the Parliament and
the Assembly they're doing much much
better than we are actually we are
recycling rate is less than places like
South Korea we have to look at but it's
like Germany Belgium which have really
got really really good schemes in place
there are many many models but they're
consistent models which roll out
programs which people understand which
people are clear about they have that
local leadership and they have that
national leadership on it this is really
a failure of governmental leadership we
could be so much better we need the
political will to excel in all these
areas and the idea that Rob said about
you know plastic bags can be recycled
actually they can't and that's why they
go to landfill yes we have to put stuff
in landfill but let's put it there let's
there dig it up again when we have the
technology to be able to recycle so at
least those things aren't lost you know
there's a way of doing these things much
more effectively but the answer is not
to ditch recycling the answer is to get
better right across the plant and just
on Rob's point there Jonathan about the
government maybe shouldn't be demonizing
landfill that much and we do that I can
actually get a lot of renewable energy
out of that that's something I didn't
know should we be pushing that a bit
more I don't think he using landfill as
a source of renewable energy is a good
policy goal inevitably you got to work
with what you've got the reality is that
what goes into landfill could be
recycled and it's better to recycle
first as much as we possibly can before
putting it in the landfill clearly and
then having to dig it up again at a
later date we think we can recycling it
as technology moves forward so we do
need to be pushing up our recycling
rates absolutely but we need to have
coherent policies consistent policies
using incentivizing local communities
everyone know really wants to recycle so
let's give them the financial incentives
and I think we're moving towards a
situation where we're willing to you
know kind of pay for the energy we use
pay for the water we use but at the
local level is a very blunt instrument
the local authorities have they have to
charge kind of one-off council tax
regardless of whether a household
recycles and is respond
or isn't and so we need to give more
power to local authorities be able to
implement schemes that do take account
of what's actually going on okay Rob
last word to you what should households
be doing to try and make a difference
then well I mean for me I mean if you
want to make a difference on the of
these issues at a household level and
I'm not sure that you can make a huge
difference at a household level they're
doing things like using public transport
or the Tonys annual thermostat by our
degree will probably do do more and if
councils want to encourage us to in
terms of waste encourage us that then
they're better ways of doing it I think
Jonathan's done it but incentive
incentive schemes actually work much
better it would seem than carrot and
stick and having sleeping people
sleeping in your bins so encourage
people educate people and incentivize
them that's a much better way forward I
think then you're slapping more fines on
people which i think is just going to
cause antagonism okay Rob Jonathan thank
you very much and you can get involved
with skies ocean rescue campaign by
visiting sky ocean rescue comm can also
follow that campaign on Facebook and
Twitter